portions of the following ABC special
program have been pre-recorded mine the
48th annual Academy Awards presentation
is the Quadra of the Music Center in Los
Angeles California where these crowds
have been gathering since early morning
to watch the arrival of Hollywood's most
glamorous stars for tonight's ceremony
like lovely Elizabeth Taylor in silk
chiffon over our nail georgette Art
Carney twin-turbine Oscar last year for
Tonto and me
glamorous Jennifer O'Neill margaux
hemingway wearing red and white coral in
matte Jersey George Burns best
supporting actor sunshine boy here is
Carol Kane Best Actress nominee for
Hester Street and OJ Simpson at
nonpareils Charles Bronson and wife Jill
Ireland both presenters on tonight's
show
Yemen like Audrey Hepburn just returned
from Europe here's Jack Nicholson Oscar
nominee and Best Actor category for
Cuckoo's Nest
Stockard Channing star and Paramount's
big bus Michael Douglas and Brenda
Vaccaro both nominated for Academy
Awards and Robert Shaw classical and
ocean picture actor author and
playwright
I'm delighted you are tuned to this
station we are invited to a great
celebration the 48th annual Academy
Awards tonight on the 29th of March at
the door of each opinion
on the muse
in downtown Los Angeles minutes away
from Hollywood say
the Sun simply
so
get out that old
and head on down
a wall
once you give when they're like those
spotlights here when they say that
tonight's the night of stars and cars
arrived
your wardrobe
so
grab a bus rapid kappa mike again take
us up they gonna take a hike again you
get a cheerio
incline captain Heston said he would
mine ran along with Moline on a plane to
get here ride a coat Rider
right a sleigh ride a train together if
you have no gas
the Emerald City no this is the way to
the Oscar award we must move on
so if you all go
this way
I'll make
why
the whole way
can you just feel you love feeling
can't you just sensory excitement in the
ball we're all in line a newbie
funny years ago 40 years ago I was 24
years old and you know what I would have
done part of the year I would have
jumped up on that stage and I'm gonna
dance my heart out for you it's not too
late is it
come on wave New Yorkers Oh
mr. professor if you please
you
why's that you're weakened the me remind
me
me on
thank you so much what a thrill ladies
and gentlemen I have the great honor and
privilege to introduce our president of
our Academy the Academy of Motion
Picture Arts and Sciences an eclair
Award winner producer himself mr. Walter
marish
what was wonderful and thank you so much
ray Bolger
and now good evening
this 48th presentation of awards by the
Academy of Motion Picture Arts and
Sciences coincides with our nation's
Bicentennial just as that celebration is
a proper time to examine our heritage
and renew our commitment to the future
so it's an appropriate time to consider
the role that motion pictures have
played in reflecting our society from
the earliest one real silent films to
today's extravaganzas of sight and sound
motion pictures have depicted our nation
as it really is and as it never was
certainly we filmmakers work in a most
potent medium one that has the awesome
power to inform as well as to excite and
stimulate the whole spectrum of human
emotions and so in exercising that power
we must accept the responsibility the
challenge and the opportunity to
entertain to preserve the past and to
dramatize our lives and times as we find
them our films have recorded our
triumphs and our tragedies our crassness
and our compassion our baseless and our
beauty and that is as it should be so
tonight as we present our Academy Awards
we honor our country as well as our
films for a great nation like a great
picture can stand the test of time and
the glare of critical examination and
now ladies and gentlemen a great actor
Walter Matthau
you know the original plan for this
evening called for me to do that ray
Bolger dance number I was to come by
balloon descend by parachute join the
dancers sing two choruses make my
entrance onto this stage with a Nijinsky
tight leap or an array of tightly if you
will we had to change that plan when I
came down with a severe case of panic as
a result you have just seen an ancient
showbusiness myth come true my
understudy ray Bolger went on in my
place and a star is born I don't mind I
mean he's a nice kid and well there's
room for all of us of course that
abbreviates my role and I'm left with
the housekeeping chores so let's get
them out of the way with my customary
casual charm for all years the Academy
Awards have been on television
your first host has been faced with the
grim official demand of the Federal
Communications Commission that we
explain the Academy's nominating and
voting procedures one time Helen Hayes
read it as though it were written by
James M Barrie Charlton Heston gave it
an impressive biblical quality this year
they thought it would be nice if I tried
it in a Shakespearean vein but I'd
emerge
however Shakespeare did know about the
Academy in act 3 scene 3 of Twelfth
Night he wrote I can no other answer
make but thanks and ever thanks that's
the perfect example of an acceptance
speech now here is the pitch for the FCC
all eligible Academy members may vote
for nominations for the best picture of
the year other nominations are made by
members of each academy branch or
special committees all active members
vote for all the awards of merit and
send their secret ballots to the
Academy's independent accountants Price
Waterhouse and company for tabulation
foreign language documentary in short
films are the sole exceptions only
active members who attend special
screenings may vote for them results are
known only to Price Waterhouse and
company until the sealed envelopes are
opened here as the world and some others
watch
now to present the first award a working
actress whose contralto voice may well
have taken up to the Metropolitan Opera
she preferred instead to make you laugh
in blazing Saddles the adventures of
sherlock holmes smarter brother and will
soon be seen in one ton ton the dog who
saved hollywood.appointment with the
gentleman with her is an Academy Award
winning actor who has just completed a
role in Buffalo Bill and the Indians no
one can ever forget his performance in
cabaret Joel gray